you were the oldest player in the league
yes I was it is now LeBron so nobody
knows better than you how hard it is
LeBron 38 years old to be doing what
he's doing we probably ain't gonna never
see that again not like that not at that
level you talk about all the guys that
you know played 20 some odd years and
even include myself in there you look at
the combined average I don't think we
combin average as much as what bra
average this in his last year he put all
us together I don't think we go proba
average what bra average his last year
it's a lifestyle for him there's no days
off even if he's not in the gym I bet
damn sure eating right and if he ain't
eating right that day he probably
running it off if he eating the wrong he
going to run it off that night that's
how you got to live if you want to
continue to have longevity in this
league man you got to take care of your
body first that weight room all you
basketball players don't like to be in
that weight room they get your ass in
that weight room if you're trying to
stay away from the injuries if you're
trying to have a longlasting career that
is something that is non-negotiable